اليوم
[تصفيق]
تزينت بثوب غير ثوبها الجميل الاخر اسكذا
اراها اليوم في جمال مختلف
واسطنبول جمالها مختلف اليوم
[موسيقى]
ورفاق القضيه
احييكم من صميم قلبي بكل حب واعزاز
[موسيقى]
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والجوله الثانيه منها
[موسيقى]
اتمناها
بين عيدين
شعبنا جعلنا نعيش عيدا ديمقراطيا فاشكر
شعبنا من الائتمان شكرا
اذبوا الى الصناديق
وادوا باصواتهم وافصحوا عن اراده الشعبيه
التي يريدون بشان مستقبل اولادهم اشكر
مواطنين جدا كل مواطنين
[تصفيق]
كل منسوبي افرع الحزب والافراح النسائيه
والشبابيه وكل مراقبي الصناديق وكل من
تطوعوا
ليستمر وتستمر هذه المرحله الانتخابيه
بسهوله وثلاثه
وكل فريق حمله انتخابيه اهنئهم
اهنئ نسائنا
واذرعن النسائيه شبابنا اهنئهم ايضا اهنئ
شبابنا
وكل من بذل مهجته في سبيل قضيتي حزب
العداله والتنميه
في الداخل وفي خارج البلاد بحسب الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات
ولا سيما فيما يخص النسب العاليه من
الاصوات
اشكر كل من شارك وساهم في رفع نسبه
الاصوات والمشاركه
كل الاعمال التي بذلها شعبنا
وكلفنا
والقى على اكتافنا بحمل اداره هذه البلاد
لمده خمس سنوات مقبله اشكر شعبنا اذ اناط
بنا هذه المسؤوليه العظيمه
وان شاء الله
ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سنفعل ما يجعلنا نليق
بثقتكم هذه وكما وكما كنا جديرين بثقتكم
هذه سنه جديرين فيها ماذا كنت قلت ليس الى
الاحد بل الى القبر
الى الممات الى اللحد قلنا هذا الحب لا
يتوقف هنا ولا ينتهي اوليس كذلك انظروا
الان يقولون باي باي كمال
نحن هذه المسيره المباركه لن تتوقف دائما
ما قلنا هذا
قلنا من يخدم الشعب لا يهزم ابدا قلنا
دائما ان تركيا امانه في اعناقنا ونحن
امانه في حضن تركيا وفي اعناقه اهل تركيا
وشعبها
[تصفيق]
ان اردتم يمكننا ان نضيف باي بايا ثالثا
الى لقبه باي باي كمال
أي الحمد
انتم
ابديت موقفكم هنا هذه الانتخابات اليوم
هذا الحب الذي بيننا هو تجسد
للديمقراطيه
وتبلوك فكما ان الحديد والزجاجه يتشكل
بالنار فان على علاقهنا بكم
وصلاتنا بكم هي التي اثمرت تركيا قويه لا
تهزم
الان انظروا
من هنا اخواني
هنا حساب
اوليس كان يقول الاخر انا خبير في
الحسابات هنا حساب اقدمه لشعب تركيا في
انتخابات 2018 حزب الشعب والجمهوري كان
عدد النوابه كم هل تعرفون 146
في 2023 عدد نواب حزب الشعب والجمهوري في
الانتخابات الاخيره
169 نائب
ظالم لكن
لما تعلمون المجموع
هو منح مقاعد لاحزاب لم تحصل على حتى واحد
بالمئه
من الاحزاب منحهم مقاعده نيابيه للايجار
كما تعلمون
ما الذي حدث اذا الان
عدد النواب حزب الجمهوري في المجلس 129 او
ليس خبيرا للحسابات او ليس يعلم هذه
الامور جيدا
وهكذا
عدد النواب بسبب عدد النواب الذين خسرهم
ومقاعد التي خسرها فانا ربما نغني في حزب
الشعب الجمهوري انه سيحاسب على هذا
ماذا نقول في الرابع عشر من مايو انتخابات
الثامن والعشرين من مايو
الكاسب والمنتصر فيها ومواطنون 85
باكملهم واجمعهم
لكني كنت قلت امرا اخر تذكروا نحن
سننتصب انتصارا لا يكون احد فيه خاسرا ولا
يخسر فيه احد
فاذا
المنتصب اليوم
تركيا وفقط ولا شيء غيرها
هيمقراطيه وتنميتنا
واهدافنا لم نتنازل عنها ولن نتنازل اليوم
نكون قد افتتحنا واشرعنا ابواب قرن تركيا
لكن اشبعنا ابوابها جميعا رجالا ونساء
وشبابا وشيبا وعاملين ومتقاعدين
بكل فئات شعبنا احلامهم
حققناها جميعا
من كان قلبه وعينه متوجها الينا من
الاصدقاء
رفعنا اعينهم ولم نكسرهم ولم نخيب ظنهم
ابدا وان شاء الله بعد اليوم كل نضال وكل
كفاح نخوضه انظروا الى هذا المشهد الذي
امامي والى هذا المجال رائع الان
ميدان تاريخا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انا باعتباري اسطنبوليا واسكتانيا ومن اهل
حيك احمد الله على ان يسر لي رفاقا للطريق
وللقضيه مثلكم
كل انتصار لنا
سنحتفل به معكم ايضا
والان
امامنا عامين
تفهمون ماذا ارمي تفهمون ما ارمي اليه في
اسكداك واسطنبول في الانتخابات المحليه
سنكسبها وليس كذلك
فاذا لا توقف سنعمل كثيرا
وسنسعى الان من
طلبت منك قوات الامن
وسالتهم كم من المواطنين هنا في ميدان هل
تعرفون 55 الف
الانتخابات تاتي وتمك
يذهب السيل ويبقى اثره وتبقى الحجاره
والصخور هل اصل والهدف والغايه ان تحافظ
بلادنا على موقفها قويه
[موسيقى]
كانت هي هذه نتائج الانتخابات اظهرت مره
اخرى
ان لا احده يمكنه ان يوقف انتصارات ومكاسب
هذه البلاد الان دول العالم يتصلون بي قبل
قليل اتصل بي رئيس جمهوريه اذربيجان
اخي الهام
شوكت اتصل بي
رئيس وزراء ليبيا اتصل بي ايضا
كلهم
اتصلوا متعاقبين
واحدا تلو الاخر وكلهم يقول
ان اقتضى الامر
فاعلنوا وادعونا وناتي اليكم في الحال
لان هذا الانتصاب
يحتفلون به معنا في الغرب وفي الخليج قطر
يتصلون بنا وهم ايضا يشاركوننا فرحتنا لا
احد
[موسيقى]
يمكنه ان يمد ايديه الى حقوق شعبنا
وحرياته لا يمكن لاحد ان ينظر الى شعبنا
من اعلى وان يحتقر شعبنا
او ان يسوق شبابنا الى مستنقعاته المظلمه
لا يمكن لاحد ان يهز اصابعه مهددا تركيا
ولاجل هذا
المنظمات الارهابيه والمحافل المغلقه لا
يمكن لاحد ان يلتف على ارجلنا ليوقف تقدم
بلادنا ولا يمكن احد ان يوقف شعبنا عن ان
يكون شعبا واحدا قويا شامخا
روابط اخويه قويه معا لا يمكنني لاحد ان
يكسر هذه الروابط وان يقطعها اخواني هلم
لنهتف هتافا تسمعه انصره
وتسمعه كل مقاطعات اسطنبول اخواني
حزب الشعب الجمهوري هذا اوليس يؤيد الشذوذ
الجنسي
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي او ليس يؤيد حمله
الشذوذ الجنسي الحزب الجيد وليس يؤيد
الشذو جنسي والله تلك الاحزاب الصغيره
المتسلقه الصغيره اوليستيه اي خدمه
فهل يمكنني شذوذ بك ان يتسرب الى الحزب
العداله او حزب الحركه القوميه او الى
الاعضاء الاخرين الشعب هل يمكن ان يتسرب
لا تنسوا
مقوله يونس
ما يقوله يونس امر تذكر كل
ما بني احد الا ولد من جديد
وهكذا كل انتخابات بالنسبه لنا هي ميلاد
جديد لا يمكن لاحد
ان
يهاجم مؤسسه العائله او يحاول تقويضها
وكذلك العنف ضد المراه من يقوم بذلك نقوم
باللازم بحقه
وفي المرحله المقبله كل ما وعدنا به شعبان
سنفذه لم نعد وعدا
هذا كان مبدانا لا نعد وعدا لا نستطيع ان
ننفذه وفي هذا الاطار الان اخرج في طريقي
الى انقره
هذه المره
سيكون هناك تغيير
وخطاب الشرفه
سيكون ان شاء الله في المجمع الرئاسي
بالمجمع من المجمع سنرسل بصوتنا الى
العالم باسره
هل تسمحون لنا بذلك
تسمعه كل تركيا
تستطيع هذا
لنفعل الايادي
بهذه المناسبه
المحافظات الاحدى عشر اشكرهم جميعا فردا
فردا هم من حاوياتهم السكنيه والمخيماتهم
ذهبوا الى صناديق
الاقتراعي وادلو باصواتهم رضي الله عنهم
وحفظهم الله من الافات والمصائب والكوارث
وكما ذكرت ان شاء الله خلال عام سيتم حل
كل ما يتعلق بالمساكن الدائمه خلال عام او
نحن مستعدون
شعب واحد
عالم واحد
وطن واحد
دوله واحده
سنكون متحدين شامخين
قويين اقوياء اخواننا نشكل جميعا تركيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تركي تركي
في انتظار خطاب النصر من انقره ولكن اختار
رجب طيب اردوغان ان نكون امام خطابين
الاول في اسطنبول كما تبعنا منذ قليل كان
هذا الخطاب امام مؤيدي هو انصاري لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات